[موسيقى]
احنا ملي عجبتنا الح مش عجبتنا الع كم
ظلم اتمت الحرب في غزه 100 يوم الا قليلا
وكان ختام المئويه الاولى اسبوع صاخب دموع
اهالي غزه ودماؤهم مستمره كل لحظه ونزيف
عسكري متواصل لقوات
الاحتلال
توالت الهزات السياسيه على حكومه نتنياهو
مع اتساع الخلاف داخل الكابينت القناه
الثانيه ع الاسرائيليه كشفت عن خلاف نشب
بين رئيس الوزراء ووزير الدفاع يو اف
جالنت على خلفيه منع نتنياهو رئيسي جهاز
الاستخبارات الموساد ديفيد بيرني وجهاز
الامن الداخلي الشباك رونين بار من حضور
جلسه لحكومه الحرب هذا الخلاف عقبه اعتراف
اعضاء في المجلس الوزاري المصغر في حكومه
الاحتلال بان الجيش لم يحقق حتى الان اي
هدف من اهداف الحرب في قطاع غزه وان قدرات
حماس ما تزال قائمه وتؤدي وظائفها تتزامن
هذه الازمه واشتداد الضغط الدولي المرتقب
على اسرائيل من القضيه التي رفعتها جنوب
افريقيا لدى محكمه العدل الدوليه متهمه
اسرائيل بارتكاب جريمه الاباده الجماعيه
في غزه ارسلت الخارجيه اسرائيليه برقيات
عاجله الى سفرائها تطلب منهم حشد ضغط دولي
ضد الدعوه بحسب موقع اكسيوس الامريكي
وعينت خبير النزاعات الاقليميه البريطاني
مالكم تشو للدفاع عنها امام المحكمه وفي
ميدان المعارك كان الاسبوع المنصرم هو
الاقصى على جيش اسرائيل منذ بدء طوفان
الاقصى بحسب وصف الاعلام الاسرائيلي اذ
سجل فيه ارتفاع كبير في عدد القتلى
العسكريين منهم تسعه ضباط وجنود قتلوا في
هجومين خلال يوم واحد ولقي ضابط اخر مصرعه
بسكته قلبيه بعد رؤيته مقتل عسكريين اخرين
واعلنت القسام تدمير 42 اليه عسكريه وقتل
22 جنديا اسرائيليا من نقطه الصفر خلال
الايام المنصرمه واستمرت النيران الصديقه
في حصد ارواح الجنود وضج الاعلام العبري
بمقتل خمسه عسكريين واصابه 30 في انفجار
شاحنه كانت تحوي مواد متفجره معده لتدمير
انفاق في
غزه يا حبيبي يا يا حبيبي
يا يا حبيبي
يا عادت اسره الدحدوح لتتصدر الشاشات هذا
الاسبوع الصحفيان حمزه وائل الدحدوح
ومصطفى ثريا سقطا شهيدين بغاره مباشره
استهدفت سياره كانا يركب
في اثناء عملهما الصحفي جنوب غزه ليس بضعه
مني حمزه كان كلي روح الروح وكل
شيء حصيله الشهداء تجاوزت هذا الاسبوع
23500 وبلغت الاصابات 60 الفا وتشير احدث
الاحصاءات الى ان 4% من سكان غزه قتلوا او
فقدوا او اصيبوا خلال 90 يوما من الحرب
وتتكشف فضاع الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه في مع
تاكيد المركز الاورو متوسطي لحقوق الانسان
سرقه الاحتلال جثامين عشرات الشهداء بعد
نبشه ا عش مقبره في غزه ويؤكد خبراء
للجزيره ان دوافع اسرائيل لنبش القبور قد
يكون لعمل ابحاث علميه تفيد في تطوير
الاسلحه الاسرائيليه وتسويقها سرقت
جثامين ضحايا بعض الاسلحه الاسرائيليه
اللي بطور التجريب واللي تم تجريبها بقطاع
غزه جزء اساسي من من
دوره بحث وتطوير هذه الاسلحه وكمان
تسويقها واطل البرد الشديد ضيفا ثقيلا على
النازحين في الخيام ليزيد معاناتهم وسط
نقص شديد في الاحتياجات الاساسيه الله
اكبر الله اكبر وفي الضفه الغربيه قتلت
اسرائيل خلال ايام 14 شخصا بينهم اربعه
اشقاء في اقتحامات استهدفت جنين وعده
بلدات اخرى وارتفعت حصيله شهداء الضفه الى
333 ووفقت هيئه شؤون الاسرى اعتقال اكثر
من
5700 فلسطيني بالضفه منذ السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي وفي جنوب لبنان استمرت المواجهات
الساخنه بين حزب الله واسرائيل بعد اغتيال
القيادي في حزب الله وسام طويل واعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي تضرر قاعده ميرون
للمراقبه الجويه بعد هجوم صاروخي لحزب
لكنه قال انه لا خطر على استمرار العمل في
القاعده هذا التوتر ياتي رغم تحركات
امريكيه تقول اداره بايدن انها تهدف الى
وقف التصعيد في لبنان والمنطقه زار وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني بلينكن خمس دول
عربيه بينها قطر بهدف منع اتساع رقعه
الصراع واكد امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن
حمد ال ثاني خلال لقائه بلينكن في الدوحه
ضروره العمل على الوقف الفوري اطلاق النار
وحمايه المدنيين في غزه وبحسب مصادر
امريكيه فان مخاوف واشنطن من اندلاع صراع
اقليمي تزداد بعد تكرار الهجمات على
المصالح الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط والتي
بلغت
115 هجوما منذ ال 17 من اكتوبر
الماضي